[Música]
hablamos ahora de salud aquí en directo
américa de france 24 más romeros olaya
con nosotros en el estudio mar sigue el
debate alrededor de las patentes de las
vacunas contra el kobe 19 en que se ha
avanzado esta semana buenos dias raúl
pues mira el 3 de mayo se publicó un
borrador en el seno de la organización
mundial del comercio con el que se llama
el grupo quad que incluye a sudáfrica
india también a la unión europea ya
estados unidos para debatir este tema
este borrador y ya se había filtrado en
marzo pero ahora ya es oficial y ya está
disponible para que lo lean y lo debatan
los 164 integrantes de la organización
mundial del comercio revisamos el primer
párrafo de este borrador básicamente
dice que a pesar de las legislaciones
nacionales durante todo el tiempo
necesario que dure la pandemia del
hobbit 19 los países pueden aprovechar
para decir a sus fabricantes que pueden
fabricar las vacunas de kobe 19 sin la
aprobación o sin el consentimiento del
fabricante original entonces pues eso
además también permite establecer
algunas normas de importación y de
exportación por ejemplo nos podrán
reexportar las vacunas que previamente
se hayan importado en el marco de este
acuerdo y también dice que se revisará
anualmente para decidir cuánto se va a
extender y que se va a modificar cual es
una buena noticia mar entonces le
pregunto como si ha recibido este
borrador pues como dices para algunos es
un gran paso porque estas modificaciones
y estos acuerdos no son fáciles y más en
temas de propiedad intelectual muchas
veces son legislaciones muy rígidas pero
para otros no es suficiente por ejemplo
médico sin fronteras lo critico
escuchamos lo
el nuevo borrador es insuficiente para
una exención de patentes significativa
que mejoraría el acceso de la gente a
las herramientas médicas contra el kobe
19 en cambio es una propuesta muy
estrecha que costará vidas urgimos a los
integrantes de la omct a rechazar este
nuevo texto y seguir construyendo
consenso alrededor de la propuesta
original
además entre las principales objeciones
por ejemplo hasta que este acuerdo
contempla que ningún país podrá fabricar
vacunas de esta manera tan libres y han
exportado el 10 por ciento de las
vacunas contra el cob y 19 a nivel
global esto por ejemplo excluye a china
que ha exportado sus vacunas a muchos
países de ingresos medios y bajos y que
tendría el potencial para convertirse en
un gran productor de vacunas de todos
los tipos y se liberarán las patentes y
hacerlo además a un precio muy bajo otra
de las críticas es que no se incluyen
los tratamientos contra el kobe 19 ni
las herramientas diagnósticas y hablemos
de tratamiento es más las dificultades
que hay para acceder a estos
tratamientos contra el cubit pues al
final es parecido a lo que pasa con las
vacunas es un tema por ejemplo de
precios sobre todo al final
es contra el 19 para encontrar el 19 los
antivirales los antiinflamatorios son
herramientas clave para enfrentar esta
pandemia no solo las vacunas y aunque en
algunos medicamentos se han llegado a
acuerdos bilaterales o multilaterales
para hacerlos algo más accesibles siguen
denunciando desde varias organizaciones
sociales que al final la vía más rápida
sería también levantar las patentes para
este tipo de enfermedades y de
medicamentos y de tratamientos hay un
ejemplo que quisiera dar un medicamento
que se llama parís it in it que es un
antiinflamatorio esto le produce la
farmacéutica eli lilly y esto en eeuu
puede llegar a costar mil dólares un
tratamiento su versión genérica en india
cuesta siete dólares del tratamiento
completo pero no se puede vender fuera
de india debido a estas restricciones de
las patentes la organización mundial de
la salud precisamente ayer también
expresaba su preocupación
es simplemente inaceptable que en la
peor pandemia del último siglo
tratamientos innovadores que podrían
salvar vidas no lleguen a quienes lo
necesitan we're playing with fire that
continuous stüber jugamos con un fuego
que nos sigue quemando vino a él
manufacturers
austin
mientras tanto los fabricantes se están
publicando ganancias récord lado ms
apoya la recompensa justa por la
innovación pero no podemos aceptar
precios que ponen los tratamientos al
alcance de los ricos y no a los pobres
and out of reach for the poor lo que
realmente impactado con ese dato que
usted dio que en eeuu es de tratamiento
que hablaba costaba mil dólares en india
podía costar hasta siete dólares y por
ahí va entonces mi última pregunta marzo
en realmente desproporcionado de estos
beneficios de las farmacéuticas sí pues
volvamos a las vacunas no nos recordaba
nuestra compañera daniela en economía
esas ganancias como de modernas se
duplicaron de facer subieron hasta el 60
por ciento y que además en el futuro
siguen pronosticando todas estas
ganancias para muchos de estos de
proporcionado respecto al nivel de
dinero público que recibieron para
desarrollar estos fármacos por ejemplo
cuánto dinero público recibieron las
farmacéuticas hablando de moderna casi
mil millones de dólares para desarrollar
su vacuna contra el cubit 19 en el caso
de janssen fueron en 910 millones de
dólares y en el caso de face de ibai
ante 800 millones de dólares
aproximadamente gracias como siempre por
toda la información un gusto conversar
de salud con usted mañana con más salud
pasamos ahora a ver nuestra segunda
invita al día